the well you're here to talk about
whatever you want you know
um I like to hear first though from
Emily Barker representing the um
Board of Medicine is she here
oh okay so houseboat 655 as you know was
a pretty beefy bill
and all of House Bill 655 was in house
bill 2. the trailer Bill to the budget
and so what we've done to make this a
little bit more
uh reasonable from a from our community
standpoint is that we took all the
repeal portion of house bill in House
Bill 655 and we took that out
the repeal portion of house bill 655.
is taken out
okay
all that is gone
so House Bill 650 655 is meant to codify
what's going to happen in oplc on the
organizational level and not on the
board level
okay and then House Bill 2
still has those portions of the repeal
in it and this committee will have a
work session on that on Friday at two
o'clock so we're essentially dividing
the bill in half
the oplc portion
and the board portion
okay
thank you so please miss Barker
Baker sorry
we need that because I never speak up
enough I'm Emily Baker I'm a physician
and the current president for the Board
of Medicine and I submit submitted a
document that at your pleasure to read
and I'm happy to answer any questions
so in the um I believe in
House Bill 2 because this has been
removed from this part of the bill has
been removed from house bill 655.
so um do you have some comments about
the
medical review board can you speak to
that because it says a component that
was in House Bill 655 and we'd like your
input on that yeah sure
the medical abuse subcommittee is
established in statute currently
as a also comprised of licensees and
public members
and does investigations on complaints
that come in through and right now they
come in through the office of oplc
and
my understanding at least from my read
of hb2 was that that was the intent was
for that to go away
and my second paragraph in my document
lends the boards
support for some version of a panel
to review complaints and assist in
investigations
and I describe what I think is sort of
in the value of a panel and it's similar
to any board where you have
more than one individual who has
potential for expertise to talk about an
investigation and make a recommendation
and whether or not
that continues in the form of where it
stands in statute currently or falls
under the Aegis of the oplc with details
to be in rules
sorry okay so on Friday that's going to
be part of the discussion at two o'clock
so if you could come back yeah that
would be appropriate would be an
appropriate conversation to have at that
time that's great I will okay thank you
I'm happy to bring some more copies of
the document I have no idea if you're
the exact same group it will be the same
group and um
I think what I'll let I'll let the
committee know when we meet to save this
document for Friday okay
not cut down any more trees yeah exactly
thank you is there anything else that
you'd like to say did you have any
questions about the review of the
applicants the first part of my
oh okay
yes go ahead
good morning Representatives Shane
Goulet attorney for the office of
professional licensure and certification
I am board counsel to the Board of
Medicine I just wanted to comment on the
board's position as it relates to the
Authority for issuing licenses there was
a portion in Dr Baker's letter and
submissions as it relates to that it's
unclear as to what that would look like
in totality but the board was concerned
with the ability to review certain
specific applications as it relates to
ones that include past disciplinary
actions in other state criminal history
it's not specific I know that it
illustrates that it would require input
and objective standards that were
created by the board so it might not be
problematic but it was certainly a
concern of the board that certain
applications would absolutely need to be
before the board that contain that type
of historic information for applicants
okay I'll make a note of that
thank you
this is the sub committee have any
questions
Mr representative Schmidt
thank you very much Madam chair
good morning everyone uh pardon my being
a little bit late
um so I'm concerned uh with regard to uh
this the smoothness of the uh the
procedure that we're potentially
embarking on here because uh you know I
I've been on this committee now for 17
years I I saw the
office of Professional Licensing and
certification come in
roughly 10 or 11 years ago
and it was a was a very new operation
there were a lot of rough edges I don't
know how many of you were here at that
time uh but now we're embarking on
something new uh in terms of of
procedure at least and my question is
whether uh what this the workability is
going to be as good as uh as it may be
after you've
uh taken off the rough edges so to speak
and do do anticipate uh an easy
transition a smooth transition to the
new procedures or are there certain
aspects that uh that you haven't even
encountered yet or haven't thought about
uh and so can you can you speak to that
because I am concerned that especially
um the the licensees you're you're going
to be working into it and you'll have
repeated instances of it because you're
doing it every day or every week some of
the people will be coming in they won't
have seen it at all and I'm wondering
whether they're going to go like I am
I'm used to turning right at this corner
like the old milk horse I'm way too old
for uh for this group in terms of Mill
courses but I remember the milk course
used to turn right at this corner
doesn't want to turn the left in the new
Administration so can you speak to that
please
I I just want to be clear representative
um that I am employed by the office of
professional licensure and certification
but my capacity here and my capacity
within that agency is specific to the
boards uh I represent the boards in
their capacity
um and my testimony here is specific and
relative to the Board of Medicine I can
say from a process and procedure
standpoint as it relates to how the
Board of Medicine has interacted with
the office and I defer to Dr Baker to
correct me if I State anything
inaccurately that it relates to the you
know expeditious
or more
expedient issuance of licenses the Board
of Medicine is working directly with the
office to ensure that that occurs kind
of hand in glove and I I think that the
board has been satisfied by the efforts
that the office has been making in
relation to that is as evidenced by the
testimony submitted by Dr Baker in
creating matrices we do have the Board
of Medicine does have a compact which
does allow for the expeditious issuance
of licenses by the office currently the
Board of Medicine is all also authorized
the office to
um
have a matrix if you will on what needs
to come before the board and what does
not to expediate the or to kind of make
the licensing process go faster is that
a fair and accurate assessment of the
board's position
and if you're make sure I've understand
your question right of whether or not we
feel that we're going to have be able to
work on this easily with the board I
mean we've had with the oplc we're
already working with them and feel
comfortable with their staff and our
made changes and are adapting that
office well and I imagine
there may be issues and it's one of
those things where I don't know what I
don't know and if something comes up I
think the board has the ability to adapt
with the oplc what I can't say is what
license our licensees would experience
our intent our job is to protect the
public
and whether or not the licensees find it
comfortable and about the role of the
oplc is of secondary importance
so that if we can get our job done well
with the current structure we will work
with it absolutely and I don't have any
concerns about that
follow-up
I don't know how much time you want to
spend on any of this men I'm sure
another three minutes would be good okay
then I'm going to defer till later thank
you okay thank you
so we'll see you on Friday at two
o'clock thank you so much
um I have this card here from David
something Courtney County
is that you yes would you like to speak
okay you oh you're Dr Conway
okay thank you
so will you be here on Friday as well
okay
and um Elizabeth Eaton
good morning my name is Elizabeth Eaton
I'm also an attorney with the office of
professional licensure and certification
and I'm here representing three boards
today
um I represent the Midwifery Council and
I have written testimony on their behalf
I'm here for the board of natural
scientists and I have written testimony
on their behalf as well as the Board of
Nursing with again written testimony on
their behalf with the
change here to the bill
some of the testimony may not apply
right now we'd have to kind of go back
and reevaluate but I would love to give
these um this testimony to you on behalf
of these boards and
um I don't know that I need to explain
much more than that okay and this will
be discussed on Friday because this is
to do with the repeal section of the
bill some of it does correct um I would
say that the board of natural scientists
has
concerns about the application review
process similar to The Board of Medicine
and so that would apply even with the
without even when you're taking out the
repeals
because licensing is Shifting in that
first section under oplc
[Music]
um otherwise I'd have to take a look at
what we've written here and really okay
so anything that so I should say this is
this is the process that representative
McGuire and I have envisioned for this
the house bills 465 Amendment will have
everything that's in House Bill 465 plus
some comments that were made at the last
committee meeting up until the repeal
section
that part of the house bill 46 655 will
be taken out of house bill 2. and it
will stand alone on its own
the repeal section we're going to take a
look at that and make comments on that
at any amendments that have to be made
to House Bill 2 will be made as a
non-germanic amendment to a bill that we
will have retained in this committee
right so that
if we don't get it all right the first
time around
we can amend whatever amendments need to
be done
we'll do over the summer for the next
year
says that does everybody understand that
okay good thanks certainly I I guess
coming here I didn't know that those
parts were going to be correct you know
and I'm here on behalf of boards who
took votes to send testimony and so I'm
just going to send the testimony as it
is yes uh and then we can go from there
and you'll be here on Friday yes thank
you
okay and is there anyone else that would
like to speak I have a car for Dr Warner
is there anyone else other than Dr
Warner that would like to speak
ah yes
okay all right would you like to come Dr
Warner we have your email
you can come before us
I want to give time to the committee to
the subcommittee to discuss this so
um do you have any comments in addition
to the email that you sent to us uh yes
I do especially since you're looking at
splitting it this way yeah
um if you were to look in my email there
is an attached document of suggested
edits for the um the bill and especially
they also I have seen the revision
suggested by actually you your name is
on it now
um and
um
there are things that
the board of mental health practice and
the board of psychology I'm speaking I'm
Dr Deborah Warner I'm in Littleton I'm
speaking as an individual I'm very well
informed about these board things having
been involved in boards but I'm speaking
as an individual just want to make it
very clear
there are things that those two boys I
did about 12 years ago about the same
time oplc was generated that were
Advanced and are especially good ways of
conducting board business and things
like protecting patient rights and
medical records privacy which did get
put into this revision as well as other
things like the
um
the protection of the allegation status
and the disclosure about that and things
like that that are very important and I
believe should be promulgated across the
boards and I think it would be good to
include it in the first sections the 310
sections that are being separated out
from the other parts that are the
repeals because I think they're just
very good ways to do this across Sports
some things in the first portion the 310
section that particularly alarmed me are
in the 310 colon 9 where the board the
oplc is allowed to initiate
investigations of its own
and not requiring a board order where
it's structured and has charges to be
investigated and inquired about and that
there'd be limitations to that process
the concern with that is that oplc or
any state agency that doesn't have guard
rails like that can do investigations on
whim they can do it on on their own
bias or whatever there could be I think
we have a good functioning oplc office
I'm not charging them with anything but
without it being in the law I think it
could get out of hand and I don't think
we want that to happen so various of my
my things if you were to look at my
attachment that has edits for the three
tens I believe that those are very
germane to the portion that you're
looking at keeping in this Bill thank
you thank you does anyone have any
questions
no okay thank you all right thank you
do you wish to speak uh attorney
osterhound or executive director
Courtney
foreign
you know what I don't need pink cards I
really appreciate the convenience but
this is not like a real this is a
subcommittee hearing so we don't
I'm not going to really save them
perfect
um well then thank you madam chair for
the record my name is Lindsay Courtney
I'm the executive director of The Office
of professional lace Insurance
certification and with me at general
counsel Douglas osterhout
gotta correct this time
um
so essentially the proposed amendment
would
eliminate all of the proposed repeals
um that are presently in 655 and just
focus on the recodification of oplc and
310. practically I think as I've
expressed before it's quite difficult
for individuals to know where to look
when it comes to oplc's Authority
because it's tucked up before all of the
other technical statutes in 310a1 a
um and so I think recodification is just
necessary in order to provide that
transparency as to what law actually
applies
additionally one of the objectives that
I think oplc has and certainly I think
has been expressed in legislation
throughout the last several years is
that there's a need to streamline the
way we do business in the office and so
this proposed amendment really provides
a consistent regulatory framework for
how the licensing boards are supposed to
operate both with respect to licensing
and with respect to discipline now
because the repeals are not proposed
here there would still be some conflicts
in the law and I think certainly the
boards that do have conflicting
Provisions there would be an opportunity
for them to rely on those statutes to
some extent we'd have to do that legal
analysis but I think it provides a
pathway for us to start streamlining and
consolidating the way we do business and
I think frankly it's pretty necessary
um you know given our limited resources
regarding Dr Warner's specific concerns
I we the proposed statute does not
contain specifically the statutory
um
requirements that there be an allegation
and then that's elevated to a complaint
practically that's the way our
investigations are already handled
essentially they are screened there's a
determination of whether or not they can
move forward
um once it's determined that the Acclaim
has been is potentially viable then it
there's an order of formal investigation
in the psychology context that would be
when an order of formal investigation
would issue and be elevated to
complaints so practically I don't see a
distinction in terms of the guardrails
for investigation I would say the
guardrails are what the guardrails are
for the board and that our investigative
Authority would be limited to to
determining whether or not there's been
a violation of something within the
board's jurisdiction we don't have
plenary powers we're not a police we're
not a law enforcement agency so
certainly there are significant
limitations on what we would be able to
do I'll turn it over to Douglas to see
if if he has any other
um items I hate like to adjust
with that I'd be happy to answer any
other questions
I'm hoping that after Friday when we
review the rest of the house bill 2
those conflicts will go away
you know between the amendment so I hope
you'll be here on Friday I certainly
plan on playing here okay great great
great great
uh representative Schmidt
again I I want to consult with the chair
with regard to how much we're going to
get into details here uh and how much is
going to be deferred until Friday uh but
um for those of you who are relatively
recent to the whole process uh you may
not be aware that you know there there
is a history involved in some of this uh
that I'm concerned about and
specifically uh you know the the board
of mental health practice originally
grew out long before I came into the
legislature out of the board of
psychologists okay
and gradually over the years uh in the
somewhat distant past the board of
mental health practice grew up around
what had originally been the board of
psychology
and about roughly 10 years ago the
psychologist came in
to Edna and they said you know within uh
the new bill saying this is not really
working we need to have our own board
and and the LED and this committee
looked at this very carefully and
ultimately determined that we were going
to give the psychologists their own
board again and keep the board of mental
health uh practice intact except for the
removal of the board of psychology now
we're talking about putting that back
together again and I have real concerns
as to whether this is uh you know a
solution in search of a problem because
to some degree to the to the ASP that to
the degree that we are trying to get
more efficient and and and smoother and
easier and more uniform that there's
some theoretical benefit to that but in
the Practical world the question I have
is is it is the return on investment
really justified by the amount of
disruption that may be caused by this
process
and this is something that that I think
we have to give some consideration to to
see whether we're spending a dollar to
get you know uh 50 cents worth of
benefit and whether we're in enhancing
our procedures at the expense of the
practitioners and the public so I want I
want everybody to be mindful of this
particular aspect is to see whether we
are we are
getting bang for the buck and and if you
can speak to any of those aspects at
this time I'm I would be happy to hear
that if Friday is better I'm willing to
wait until then as well thank you
representative I I can speak to the fact
that the proposed changes that you speak
of are not in this bill and not in this
proposed amendment they're in hb2
certainly but not in this proposed
amendment this proposed amendment
wouldn't impact the current structure of
any of those boards it would just
provide
um a consistent way that we issue
licenses but licenses in the agency as
well as manage investigations and
disciplinary proceedings
thank you I think that's very helpful
intent of the amendment was to do that
so I think the the purpose of the
amendment is to get house this part of
the codification of oplc under 310 and
to allow them to
go on with that and leave the rest of it
in House Bill 2 so that and that gives
us more time really because we just got
House Bill 2 Thursday gives us more time
to look at those elements in it that are
more complicated and that overlap with
existing statutes so that was the
purpose for the house bill 655 Amendment
Nikki if I may represent him just add
one more Point
um with respect to the licensing uh
process that's proposed in this amended
version of 655
it's consistent with what the large
majority of our boards already do and
that the large majority of our boards
have already delegated the authority to
us to issue licenses unless there are
obviously questions regarding criminal
history checks which would still be
reviewed under this proposed structure
only a handful of boards still review
applications on a very regular basis
most boards have delegated that to us
because they recognize one that it
largely is just an administrative
function to make sure that all criteria
is satisfied because it's objective and
then two there are serious Workforce
challenges with having to wait every 30
60 90 days to review and possibly issue
licenses so it's consistent with what we
are doing but there have been concerns
raised by
the LBA in audits performance audits as
to whether or not boards have the
authority to delegate that Authority so
this way this would essentially clear up
that question
foreign
I think that's very helpful to have this
dissociation as discussed early on that
you've already thought through this to a
considerable degree I think that's very
helpful for us to have confidence that
we're not getting from here to
Manchester by way of Los Angeles okay
thank you
is there anyone
this yes rep attorney
I'll be very brief uh shengue attorney
with the office of professional
licensure and certification I'm here on
behalf of the Dental Board the board of
land surveyors the Board of Professional
Engineers and the board of accountancy
the board of accountancy has written
testimony may I approach with it you may
I believe the board of accountancies
written testimony speaks for itself uh
to the best of my ability I'll answer
questions as it relates to that as far
as the land surveyors and the
Professional Engineers uh they did meet
yesterday and wanted to put on the
record that they are in opposition to
655 full stop that was the vote that
they gave me to represent to this
committee today as it relates to the
Dental Board they had a few specific
concerns again this is notwithstanding
the amendment because they were not
aware of that that may or may not change
their opinion as it relates to that I
couldn't make any representations as it
relates to that here today but
specifically as it regards the Dental
Board they did have concerns with the
complaint process and procedure and the
vetting of the complaints having the
complaints come into oplc and having
them conduct the investigation without
any input from the board was problematic
for them they view their own
professional expertise and ability to
view those complaints of prime
importance and utilizing those expertise
they are aware that oplc does have the
authority to contract with necessary
experts but that was their input as it
related to that specific concern the
other concern when reviewing the 655
that was currently constructed prior to
the amendment was that there was no
consideration as to what constitute
professional misconduct as it related to
their specific profession so what if
anything they were to utilize so that
was a concern that they noted that also
applies to their reciprocal discipline
because that was within the same repeal
again that is not concerned given the
fact that there's an amendment here
today but they wanted to put that on the
record they